[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tiens une pomme
penser à isaac vous savez tous vous avez
tous en tête la mésaventure qui lui est
arrivée il avait décidé de se faire une
petite sieste au pied d'un arbre quand
tout à coup ce fruit qui avait décidé de
vivre sa vie est venu percuter le crâne
sur le coup un réveil un peu brutale un
peu douloureux mais dans un second temps
il venait de découvrir
la gravitation universelle
au passage se sheikh isaac newton nous
vanter un des mérites de la sieste
mais pour revenir à la découverte de la
gravitation universelle ce type de
découverte un peu inattendu est attribué
un phénomène qui s'appelle la
sérendipité
7 sérendipité s'applique aussi si c'est
une invention lié à une erreur ou un
échec ou encore quand c'est le résultat
ou le fruit de travaux sur un tout autre
sujet
la pénicilline le post it le micro ondes
le viagra dans l'histoire de l'humanité
des centaines des milliers d'inventions
sont attribués à la sérendipité
la sérendipité est présente dans nos
quotidiens à tous on en est déjà tous
profiter
même si vous n'en êtes pas conscient
c'est ce que j'ai envie de vous partager
aujourd'hui
au fait je me suis pas présentée je
m'appelle françois hot hot avec un h
comme heureux d'être avec vous hot avec
trois lettres trois lettres un peu comme
les trois étages de la tour eiffel
mais c'est aussi les trois envie que
j'ai de très longue date
la première c'était jouer d'un
instrument de musique la deuxième des
présidents de la république et la
troisième de faire un télex
alors pour ce qui est de l'instrument de
musique on est entre nous je dois
admettre que ça va faire bientôt
cinquante ans que j'hésite entre eux le
piano et la guitare électrique
pour ce que la présidence de la
république il ya un autre françois h kim
a devancé mais on en reparlera tout à
l'heure et puis le tedx
une ambition non plutôt un rêve
inaccessible
et pourtant j'ai comme l'impression
qu'il n'est pas en train de se
concrétiser et tout cela grâce à la
sérendipité
le mot sérendipité est apparue en 1754
c'est un certain horace walpole qu'il a
inventé cet écrivain anglais qui
cultivait l'art de la découverte s'est
inspiré d'un conte persan les trois
princes de serendip
alors en gros c'est l'histoire de trois
frères qui décident de quitter leur papa
roi de serendip pour une sorte de very
bad trip à la recherche de l'amour et
qui quelques mois plus tard reviennent
riche d'émotions mais surtout de savoir
et de découvertes dans des domaines dont
il n'avait jamais entendu parler
mais au fait qui parmi vous considère
que tout ce qui lui est arrivé dans la
vie jusqu'à présent d'agréables ou de
désagréable avait été prévu ou planifiés
par lui par carrère d'autres
bons parce que si l'inde autre si l'un
d'entre vous avaient affirmé que c'était
le cas je me serais permis d'avoir
quelques doutes
alors la sérendipité en fait c'est la
capacité d'accueillir de façon positive
tout ce qui nous arrive dans la vie et
surtout ce qui est improbable inattendue
même ce qui est désagréable
parmi les définitions de la sérendipité
il y en a une que vous retiendrez à coup
sûr c'est celle de pecs vendre en deuil
la sérendipité c'est chercher une
aiguille dans une meule de foin et
trouver la fille du fermier
alors la sérendipité et donc à l'oeuvre
dans nos quotidiens respectifs même si
nous n'en sommes pas conscients en
particulier pour ceux d'entre vous qui
découvraient ce terme à l'occasion de
cette prise de parole
parmi les moments de la vie où la
sérendipité joue un rôle joue souvent un
rôle on peut citer
la recherche d'un emploi ou souvent
l'effet réseau le rebond d'une
candidature favorise le succès
la recherche d'un logement celui que
l'on trouve en finale est souvent très
différent de celui qu'on avait imaginé
initialement
les réunions de famille vous savez où
les réunions entre amis vous savez celle
où on va à reculons et qui parfois se
transformer en moment fort sympathique
ne partage de rencontre
le voyage en terre inconnue vous savez
celui où on pas on part juste avec le
billet aller en se disant on improvisera
sur place et puis
la rencontre de l'âme soeur
entre nous est-ce que ce matin là vous
vous êtes dit ce soir je vais rencontrer
un être formidable qui va changer ma vie
dans notre quotidien il ya un endroit
que nous fréquentons tous et qui est
source de serbie pitt est en permanence
c'est internet en effet il nous est tous
arrivé à l'issue d'une séance de surf
sur le web d'avoir appris quelque chose
fait une découverte ou fait une affaire
la prochaine fois vous ferai une petite
affaire sur eux je ne sais quel site
marchand pourrait dire c'est de la faute
à la sérendipité
mais
déclenché la sérendipité en fait c'est
mission impossible
mais rassurez vous il ya moyen de se
débrouiller pour la favoriser
pour vous prouver je vais vous partager
deux histoires personnelles
tout d'abord la rencontre avec évent
va est une étudiante de ce climat que
nous avons eu la chance d'accueillir
comme alternantes à la direction
innovation l'an dernier eva avait vu une
de mes conférences sur la sérendipité et
ayant appris que son école dont elle est
très fière
organisé son premier thé luxe elle m'a
convaincue de déposer une candidature
bien qu'apôtre de la sérendipité je
n'étais pas du tout convaincu alors pas
du tout va de l'intérêt de faire une
intervention sur ce sujet de plus cet
exercice ne semblait hors de portée je
ne m'en sentais ni la capacité ni la
crédibilité pour le faire et pourtant
je suis là
cette première anecdote illustre
quelques clés qui favorise la
sérendipité
ayant découvert ce concept il ya un peu
plus de trois ans celui ci m'a beaucoup
aidé dans la vie
c'est sûrement là envie de le partager
qui a constitué une sorte d'intuition
faisons confiance à eva j'ai mis de côté
la raison qui me donner moult exclure
pour décliner sa proposition raisons qui
m'incitaient plutôt à attendre d'avoir
des certitudes pour me lancer dans ce
défi
j'ai donc pris le risque de m'aventurer
en terre inconnue en saisissant une
opportunité une une opportunité
improbable
120 goût pour la découverte pour
l'ouverture d'esprit et un mais aussi un
certain goût pour le challenge je ne
serais pas en train de vous parler
alors vous pourriez me dire que le
hasard ne fait bien les choses que dans
des situations positif
détrompez vous je vous partage et une
autre anecdote
avril 1989 mon père est victime d'un
infarctus
partir à 56 ans et un poteau
père re son papa 29 ans c'est vraiment
pas cool
quinze mois plus tard
valentin donc en juillet 1990 valentin
notre premier enfant né c'est
entre ces deux dates j'ai eu beaucoup de
temps pour repenser à tout ce que
j'avais vécu et surtout ce que je
n'avais pas vécu avec mon père
une véritable leçon de vie qui m'a
apporté de précieux enseignements
qui ont été très utiles pour la relation
et l'éducation de nos trois enfants
entre révolte et sidération
c'est l'incompréhension qui domine dans
ce type de situation
on aimerait tellement rembobinez le film
afin d'être épargnés ou encore avoir la
possibilité de vivre ou de faire quelque
chose avec la personne qui nous a
quittés et pourtant
la seule attitude recommandé c'est
d'accepter ce qui nous arrive
cela permet de vivre à fond l'instant
présent avec les personnes qui nous
entourent
et pourquoi pas
attendre de bonnes surprises
chaque fois que dans la vie nous sommes
confrontés à des situations désagréables
se rappeler la maxime qui sait c'est
peut être bon à quelque chose
face à des difficultés des épreuves des
contrariétés se dire que toute chose
travail pour notre bien et une source de
bienfaits peut-être de réconfort
sûrement
en substance pour la sérendipité ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est de se dire
qu'il faut accepter de ne pas tout
maîtriser et surtout lâché prise
j'ai lu récemment
que suite aux attentats du 11 septembre
une entreprise qui avait ses bureaux
dans le world trade center avait fait
une enquête auprès de ses salariés
survivants
il s'agissait pour elle de savoir
pourquoi
il n'était pas à leur poste à 8h42 au
moment où les avions ont percuté les
tours jumelles
écoutez
et un chef de service qui est arrivé
très en retard parce que ce matin là
c'était le premier jour à l'école
maternelle de son fils
un comptable alors qu'il s'apprêtait à
partir adieu se changer complètement
parce qu'il venait de se renverser un
grand bol de café sur lui
un trader
n'est pas arrivé parce qu'il était à la
maternité parce que dans la nuit il
avait dû accompagner son épouse qui
avait décidé je ne sais pas mais qui a
couché avec plusieurs jours d'avancé par
croyable
cet informaticien lui a attendu très
longtemps le taxi qu'il avait réservé la
veille sur son application
parce que l'application avait buggé mais
l'histoire la plus incroyable c'est une
histoire de ce futur employé qui ce
matin là pour se rendre à son entretien
d'embauché s'étaient équipés de
chaussures neuves et il a dû faire
escale dans une pharmacie pour traiter
l'an poule qui risquait de lui gâcher sa
journée
alors
la prochaine fois que votre réveil ne
sonnera pas ou que vous serez bloqués
dans le métro à la station châtelet
dites vous ce n'est pas si grave et
c'est peut-être pour votre bien
prenez les choses avec philosophie
ne soyez ni fâché ni frustré vous êtes
juste au bon endroit tiens en parlant de
bons endroits
il y en a un qui était vraiment bon
endroit c'est françois h françois
hollande qui est élu le 15 mai 2012 et
bien beaucoup d'analystes politiques
s'accordent à penser qu'il n'aurait
jamais été élu si un an et un jour
auparavant il y avait passé un scandale
dans un sofitel du côté de new york
2012 au passage c'est aussi l'année
d'entrée qui m'ont sérendipité dans les
dictionnaires français
alors pour terminer je vous proposais
une petite fable
c'est l'histoire d'un fermier chinois
qui est un cheval blanc dont il est très
fier un jour son cheval s'enfuit de son
enclos les voisins du fermier viennent
vers lui et lui disent mais quelle
malchance et le fermier de répondre
peut-être
le lendemain le cheval réapparaît et il
est accompagné de 12 jument
est là les voisins de s'exclamer de
quelles chances
et notre fermier de répondre peut-être
le fils du fermier
décide alors de monter sur une des
juments sauvage et il tombe et se casse
la jambe et les voisins de dire
quelle malchance
peut être répond le fermier
quelques jours plus tard l'armée
débarque au village pourrait questionner
tous les jeunes hommes pour partir à la
guerre à part le fils du fermier avec sa
jambe cassée
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]